bonjour je pardon ça fait trois mois que
t'as pas mis un pistache youtube et à
être comme ça comme une fleur bah désolé
en fait je vous exprimer j'espère thème
bonne excuse
ben justement à ce propos quoi bon
chahut un rhume s'était cassé un ongle
je t'écoute
non c'est pas ça en fait j'écris la vie
en fait à hyères excuses à mon bon je
suis très heureux et très fier
d'annoncer que ça y est je suis papa
j'suis pas [ __ ] c'est un truc de ouf
je sais même pas par où commencer
tellement le truc énorme
en tout cas là je crois que jamais été
aussi heureux toute ma vie même bravo à
l'âme avant un qui a participé beaucoup
au projet quand même bon genre plus la
nuit 1 mais au moins ça justifie mes
cernes pour une fois eh ouais maintenant
je suis responsable d'un petit être
vivant n'importe où n'importe quand
excusez moi excusez moi c'est marrant
quand j'ai commencé des vidéos je vous
parlais de jouer au ping pong qui aurait
cru que huit ans plus tard
[Musique]
premièrement vous seriez toujours là que
je vous parlerai d'avoir un bébé c'est
au fleix bon pas générique
[Musique]
je pas le premier à avoir un bébé je
regardais sur google ce mardi un chiffre
pour sa 107 milliards 602 millions sept
cent soixante sais je sais pas dire ce
chiffre mais ça fait beaucoup
bah plus rien du coup même si ce chiffre
est énorme
chaque naissance et unique est vécu
différemment un mot je suis personne
pour parler au nom de tous les parents
donc je vais simplement partager ma
petite expérience personnelle est encore
un petit extrait abbas l'a tellement de
trucs à dire alors par rapport aux bébés
beaucoup me demande son prénom son sexe
et son numéro de sécu et comme je tiens
quand même à ma vie privée et au respect
de son anonymat
dans la vidéo mon enfant sera incarné
par lui plutôt réaliste 1 à huy sur la
miniature le bébé c'est un bébé issu
d'une photos libres de droits un docu
sais pas qui sait peut-être qu'un jour
ses parents pour se promener sur youtube
fr
avoir un bébé c'est notre fils pour
quant à un bébé ton mode de vie change
complètement
un tueur y êtes toute ta vie c'est
presque une deuxième vie qui commence
maintenant mon bruit préféré c'est celui
ci a bravo oui
yes mon style vestimentaire j'en ai
clairement plus rien à [ __ ] non mais
tamimi leggings et où le bébé n'a au
lavage un plein soutien
je me disais aussi retire ce legging
c'était celui de l'épisode quoi
maintenant pour sortir je prends le
strict minimum
allez y est avec la maman on n'a jamais
été aussi proche
ça te dirait qu'on est un
aucun rapport sexuel or si je découvre
de nouveaux problèmes existentiels
[Musique]
le message dormir est devenue
parfaitement impossible
1 je suis tellement fatigué que je fais
n'importe quoi
voilà un homme beaucoup de parents je
suis persuadé que ma bouche est à 70 et
la tune qui tombe par terre
aussi voilà bah c'est propre
plus moyen d discret en public
ouais ouais à la base ne connais pas je
ne sais pas qui c'est moi qui sais pas
c'était ma famille et mes plus belles
victoires sont pas forcément celles que
j'imaginais sans dire qu'il est constipé
[Musique]
ah ouais c'est de la merde mais après
c'est un mode de vie un an quelques mois
j'ai appris des milliers de choses
geagea paix que les nouveau nés les
premiers mois il voit flou et en noir et
blanc
wen voit comme ça ouais j'ai aussi
appris que par exemple les nouveau nés
ils ont différents types de pleurs
correspondent à différents signaux un
type de pleurs pour dire que la fin un
type de pleurs pour dire qu'il a froid
etc
et j'avoue qu'au bout d'un moment tu
reconnais la nuance tu deviens un peu
experts je veux du bon le problème voilà
ramia la couverture je comprends était
un peu trop voilà on est bien mieux là
c'est clair le dernier épisode de game
of thrones nul à chier abuser ah ouais
ouais non mais c'est à west ham et c'est
clair l'accouchement
c'était juste et fort je me rappelle
j'arrive à la maternité un petit peu en
retard et j'ai vu cette sage-femme
sortir avec lui tout petit être humain
je me suis approché nos regards se sont
croisés pour la première fois et c'est à
cet instant que j'ai vraiment le
sentiment d'être père
et puis la sage femme m'a dit le vôtre
il a prêté mission à bon on semble un
peu quand même
[Musique]
quand tu viens d'avoir un bébé
en plus de vivre un truc extraordinaire
j'imaginais pas mais fait tout le monde
se félicite donc des cadeaux au centre
de l'attention max limite son
anniversaire
bravo m maintenant déchire merci
[Musique]
félicitations pour ton bébé quand le
bébé merde
le court être parent ça rend forcément
responsable c'est est responsable d'un
si petit truc si fragile tu peux pas
faire le truc à moitié et en tant que
papa tu prends ta mission très à coeur
on put devient quelqu'un d'autre ça a
presque un côté un peu viril je serais
prêt à donner ma vie pour la tienne
ma devise aller sans alliés force et
précision les coups et blessures
plus rien il ne faut rien laisser au
hasard
on m'appelle le professionnel
[Musique]
c'est la mienne tu as beau avoir une
petite déco style et chez toi quand tu
as un nouveau-né ya rien à faire ta
maison devient inévitablement une
garderie toi tu te transformes en nous
et quand organise une soirée chez toi
soyons honnêtes c'est plus vraiment
comme avant ça vous colle à elles sont
où les meufs ce soit on se pète le crâne
de mekin je vous le dit on chez châtain
s'il vous plaît on se lave les mains
pour les microbes dans la plaie
chaussures bon pas d'alcool mais pour la
musique
j'ai tout prévu bah comme un soir elle
vous plaît pas on fait ça peut être une
soirée jeux vous a fait venir à 14
heures et enfin l'un des moments les
plus durs pour moi c'est le moment où tu
confies ton enfant pour la première fois
à un ou une baby sitter
c'est assez difficile bon ben voilà on
rentre dans deux trois heures à peu près
on a confiance en vous alors un petit
regard au revoir un petit bisou aussi
aller oui on va faire comme ça merci en
tout cas on fait vraiment confiance
bref je plaisante sur les petits tracas
quant à un nouveau né la maison je vous
assure que je vis la plus belle ta de ma
vie je vous souhaite à tous de vivre ça
un jour de mon côté il me reste plein de
trucs à découvrir la vie de papa elle
est sans fin bon j'avoue que je me suis
pris une petite pause maternité pendant
quatre mois
mais ne croyez pas que ce nouveau statut
de papa va m'empêcher de faire des
vidéos 1 nous ne croirons croyez pas ça
au contraire ça donne plein d'idées de
d'énergie créative
donc restez connecté il ya du lourd qui
va arriver et j'vais dead sa merci pour
tous vos petits messages de
félicitations et c'est hyper mignon
évidemment ça m'a beaucoup touché
donc merci beaucoup enfin un gros bisou
et je vous dis à bientôt moi j'aime
m'occuper de mon bébé par en plastique à
la main de son père j'ai dit à l'ats
jeudi elle pas trop tard j'ai dit c'est
une fille
[Musique]
là
moi
[Musique]